coucou moi je m'appelle jzou euh
j'aimerais savoir si tu as déjà fait des
choses illégales mais dans tous les cas
j'adore tout ce que tu fais tu es grave
drôle reste copté ah ça fait plaisir
j'ai une bêtise parfois j'y repense la
nuit et tout je me dis pourquoi j'ai
fait ça quand j'étais plus jeune je suis
parti à Londres avec un pote je bois pas
d'alcool mais à l'époque je sais pas
j'is bu pour la soirée et il y a un taxi
qui me ramène chez moi j'avais pas
d'argent pour retirer donc je lui dis
laissez-moi à l'angle pour retirer et là
je vois une petite ruelle sombre j'avais
bu et j'avais ma capuche j'étais
persuadé que j'étais dans le le jeu
vidéo Assassin's Creed je suis allé
retirer je suis parti en courant j'ai
fait un taxi basket et après j'ai marché
3 jours dans Londres en étant persuadé
qu'un jour il y avait une camionnette
qui allait s'ouvrir on allait mettre un
sac sur la tête et me kidnapper et dir
ils sont où les 20 pounds que tu nous
dois monsieur je m'engage si un jour on
se recroise à vous rembourser